I have about seven credit cards um with
very little balance if anything they're
just my remedial um uh they're paying
for like Netflix you know like stuff
like that on payment plans every month
for those for that kind of stuff um
however it does amount to over
$100,000 of open credit with lenders
like seeing how much credit cards I've
have I have is there a problem with um
that the me having so many credit cards
do I need to close some I don't want to
close any because it hurts you know I
know it hurts your credit score um okay
but I'm Sean you called a kind of a
different show just so our advice is
going to be probably opposite of what
you usually he because we are not fans
of credit cards we're not even fans of a
credit score we're not fans of keeping
around debt we want debt in that entire
game that everyone plays out of your
life 100% forever ever amen